hey it's evan i hate spammers and
they're getting smarter and smarter in
how they are reaching out to people and
i wanted to share an example that came
in recently from company had never heard
of called Valachi so this this woman
writes to me Lee Carver here she is
social media specialist at vellachi
supposed to be great at social media
here she sees what she writes in hi are
you still updating a mechanical calm I
found a broken link I'd like to point
out Lee so not customized to me right no
name only my website something easy to
pull down no value add so show me where
that link is if you've actually found
something for me Lee and here we are
friends of your site unsubscribe from
this list are you kidding me you're
saying that I'm on a list right here on
this page so the first thing I'm going
to do when I see this is I'm going to
unsubscribe if I didn't already there
you go unsubscribe successful I no
longer want to receive these emails I
never signed up for this mailing list
the emails are inappropriate he was our
spam which should be reported other can
I select all of these oh it's too bad
just one submit MailChimp I hope you
guys block these guys the emos are spam
and should be reported i don't know how
i ended up on this list and it's blatant
spam and they're getting smarter listen
guys Valachi you want to make a
difference you want people to buy your
social media services or whatever the
heck it is that you sell give me a
reason to talk about you give me
something that makes you different give
me something that says here's what your
place in the world is here's how you see
a different vision of how the world
should be and make me feel something
right now all I think is the guise of
villages are a bunch of spammers and I'm
not going to say anything good about
them if I'm going to talk about you at
all it's going to be making a video like
this about how crappy you are and how
you're sparing people this is not a win
okay this is not how you reach out to
people and get them to get involved with
your business you got to offer value
it's okay to email people and tell them
that there's a broken link but make it
credible right hi Evan here's a broken
link here's the URL and don't say that
on some list okay this is not how you're
going to stand out let me know you guys
think do you hate spammers do you get
this kind of stuff are you pissed off
like I am
let me know leave a comment below if you
like this video give it a thumbs up
let's eliminate the spam from this world
thank you guys I'll see you soon